ladies focused away of the strangers and
counters with the Islamic state grab
wood hey Graham how you doing hate to
see you okay so you wrote the book on
Isis that can't be easy and I remember
when you wrote in the Atlantic about it
and we had an attack this week from
somebody who was making no bones about
the fact that he was in with Isis right
yeah singing the fight song from his
hospital bed oh really
and you wrote back in in the Atlantic in
2015 the reality is that the Islamic
state is Islamic very Islamic the the
religion preached by most of its ardent
followers derives from coherent and even
learned interpretations of Islam what do
you mean by that
well you know people say Isis has
nothing to do with Islam and what I'm
suggesting is that it's part of the
Islamic tradition you know the Islamic
tradition is 1,400 years long and it is
diverse and Isis has a piece of that it
is a phenomenon that comes from that
tradition it's not the only thing that
you could you heart a was Islamic but
it's looking at things like the idea of
a caliphate
like the idea that there are particular
laws that were handed down from the
beginning and it is implementing them in
a way that would be recognizable to
Muslims from many many centuries before
when people say a religion is it's
almost a silly thing to say right
because it's practiced by different
people in different ways and with some
people it is AI system of course many
more people it is not but to just say it
is a religion of peace hopefully to all
unfortunately not to all yea most
Muslims do not consider Isis the best
representation of the religion but we
could say that about various Christian
sects too and we're totally used to
talking about Christianity as having a
crazy fringe a kind of mainstream center
peaceful Christians warlike Christians
and Isis happens to be one part of that
spectrum with the difference with the
Islamic world is that the there are many
more fundamentalists mainstream people
yeah or what we would call
fundamentalists I think the best
analogue within Christianity might be
the Westboro Baptist Church which is
that this group that
used to pick it the funerals of
servicemen yeah and they'd pick at me
they're like Fitz it's a small group
with with Isis unfortunately there were
about 40,000 people who traveled to
Syria right on their side so that's a
much larger proportion so when people
say that it's a double standard
how trump right now I think we all agree
Trump's solutions are horrible right
okay I would agree with that and his
reactions yet but they said there's a
double standard in the reaction to the
Vegas violence that we saw the Las Vegas
shooter about a month ago and this are
you mentioned the Westboro Baptist
Church people mentioned Tim McVeigh they
mentioned Anders Breivik they mentioned
the Ku Klux Klan is there a difference
do you see I mean there is I think you
started to say just in numbers yeah we
don't even know what happened with Vegas
yet but the difference I think is that
Isis is claiming part of this tradition
so it does have a certain way of kind of
justifying itself that's different from
other types of violence now it doesn't
mean that those other types of violence
aren't concerning in fact they in many
cases claim much larger numbers you know
59 people in Las Vegas but what Isis is
able to do is well that's during that's
this year yeah that's a one event that
guy was not trying to acquire nuclear
weapons but he was very that's a big
very effective at killing people from
from one hotel room of course but with
with rights what we get is the the sense
that any individual Muslim can be kind
of activated in an Isis mold because of
the belief that that they can speak to
this kind of understanding that Isis is
reviving a tradition that they have some
some part of now that's that's something
that I think certain other ideologies
don't quite have the ability to do is to
try to awaken the sense that we've got
the right version of something that
you're already part of okay what do you
think is the effect when people I
mentioned this has happened to you
because you've written realistically
about this say you're your Islamophobic
yeah I have to look at some of these
issues with kind of you know trumpian
orange tinted lenses and I understand
that this is not a great time to be a
Muslim in the United States
Muslims are target's of bigotry they're
targets of actual Islamophobia but at
the same time at some point you have to
engage the [ __ ] detector and if
someone says Isis has nothing to do with
Islam then I think they're really gonna
misunderstand what's motivating people
to kill in its name and it cuts off
debate does it not it mean absolutely
does yeah I my belief has always been
that you you're never gonna solve the
terrorism problem unless you modernize
the religion that until the religion
itself has a Reformation enlightenment
like Christianity did this problem is
gonna persist
would you agree with that I think it
might even be a more dispiriting
situation than that Isis in some ways is
the reformation within Islam they're
doing what you know five hundred years
ago in Christianity we had Martin Luther
saying we don't have to listen to the
established church we don't have to
listen to the Pope Isis is saying your
neighborhood Imam forget him he doesn't
know he's talking about
we're the ones we can just read the
Quran and we're going to have an
interpretation that that is extremely
violent but it's the right one even
though we're the minority so this
modernization of Islam can go both ways
it can go in an enlightened way or it
can go toward one that's that's
unfortunately very violent and again one
of the differences I think is that there
is more support in a general population
when we get this polling back it seems
to show like twenty percent of worldwide
Muslims are what they would call
Islamist they're not terrorists they're
not taking it violently but most of the
things terrorists believe they believe
yeah they would say they want Sharia to
be represented in government but they
might mean something so different from
Isis right they would hate Isis I mean
they might they might just believe that
in some way the Constitution in their
countries should should reflect is LOM
but death for leaving the religion there
is disconcertingly highest levels of
support for that that's right
things like that which are not liberal
principles no they're not compatible
with what I would say are
you know ideas of human rights that I
would recognize okay